افاد مراسل الجزيره بسحب قوات الاحتلال
الياتها من مدينه جنين ومحيط مخيمها وذلك
عقب اقتحام اقتحام نفذته على وقع اطلاق
نار كثيف واشتباكات بين مقاومين فلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال استخدمت فيها اسلحه رشاشه
خفيفه ومتوسطه وبثت منصات محليه فلسطينيه
مشاهد الاندلاع الاشتباكات التي تلاها
تصاعد اعمده الدخان بكثافه من موقع
الاقتحام نتيجه لاطلاق قوات الاحتلال
قنابل دخانيه للتغطيه على عمليتها
العسكريه وكان مقاومون قد اطلقوا سفارات
الانذار مرتين خلال الاقتحام الساب عشر
لجنين منذ السابع من
اكتوبر ووثقت كاميرا الجزيره لحظات اندلاع
الاشتباكات في جنين واظهرت المشاهد تصاعد
اعمده الدخان بكثافه نتيجه لاطلاق قوات
الاحتلال ال القنابل دخانيه للتغطيه على
عمليتها
العسكريه نشرت منصات محليه فلسطينيه
مشاهده تظهر اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيم بلاطه بمدينه نابلس في
الضفه الغربيه الليله الماضيه كما تداولت
حسابات فلسطينيه على تيليغرام مقاطع فيديو
تظهر انفجار عبوه الناسفه واندلاع
اشتباكات المسلحه بين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاح الاسرائيلي عقب اقتحام
المخيم